hello there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the episode
7 Easter eggs and breakdown from pull
heavy spoilers to die of course joined
by my lovely friend Andrew Gordon how
are you Andrew I am doing better than
Riley and Joel but almost as good as
Ellie and hopefully as good as Paul's
gonna be if he doesn't miss another
reference like he did last week plus
references pulse
guys leave a like for heavy spoilers if
you haven't done so already he's
struggling have you seen his views
lately embarrassing also um guys at
shopzeroedition.com Paul has a shirt fun
guy here's an image real rejects same
website because we're partnered up
together got an exclusive Last of Us
shirt as well look at it I'm so proud of
it it's such an intricate design if
you've seen Shawna the dead you kind of
get a little bit of the splicing
reference here don't worry it's not a
spoiler they don't play Playstation
together at the end of this game you're
just spoiled by saying that now people
are gonna be like well now I'm expecting
them not to I know I understand how it
goes guys
calm down it's a cool shirt respect it
support the channel by buying one please
please I'm begging you this is how
YouTubers should promote their merch
please buy my [__]
so The Last of Us seven is now out and
this episode's filled with a ton of
Easter eggs callbacks to the game and a
lot of things that flesh out Ellie's
backstory totes based on the Left Behind
DLC that saw us learning more about what
happened to her during the time that Joe
was at death's door in the game
originally after he fell off the Halls
he had a massive section where he played
his hair for about an hour and you had
absolutely no idea whether Joel was
alive or dead it was agonizing fighting
through the infected to discover what
happened but yeah we find that on the
opening that he's okay you did have a
weak weight but yeah it wasn't as tense
as the hour long session I still feel
like probably by next week's episode
we'll still get the we gotta be getting
at least something related to what
occurs within that hour right I mean of
course and obviously this isn't a
spoiler but if you've seen the trailers
in loot to reference to what you're
saying yes we are going to be getting I
believe so yes in loot to reference yes
that's I just made up that word but yes
in reference to what you were saying yes
we will be getting that I from the
trailer
yes thank you for the correction see
he's not just a my one of my best
friends he's he's here to create I'm a
character of grammar he does this too
off camera he corrects me all the time
but I gotta do best here buy a shirt
now when The Last of Us Part One remake
was released last year I was thinking
that they might add in the life behind
chapter so it happened in chronological
order they didn't know and sandman's the
only show I've seen come with DLC so
they dropped it in here where it should
take place in the story what about they
do skip over a big part of it dealing
with Ellie searching for supplies in the
game the story was split in half and we
ended up getting two scenarios set
inside a mall yes throughout the DLC you
jump back and forth between the two and
in the first you saw what we get in the
mall with Riley in the second section it
was a completely different location set
in the present where you followed Ellie
as she looked for supplies this took you
to a crashed military Chopper in the
area and he found that the mall was
teaming with infected after getting the
supplies you made your way back to Joel
which is where you had to protect him
from Hunters who were out for his blood
I need something like that in the show
oh I gotta have at least 10 minutes of
Ellie surviving on her own and having a
takedown infected on her own or fight
some bad guys on her own
like 10 minutes versus you know hours
worth of doing that and with in the
video game itself because to me that's
some of the most intense of the video
game and I feel like it would only
Elevate Bella Ramsay if they provided
that I completely agree with you we we
really need to have that like that is a
very important section of the game it's
not a long extreme like major section of
the game but it is an important section
of just fleshing Ellie out more just
seeing that she can't survive on her own
as well and just shows how strong and
stoic of a character she is so I really
would be really saddened and
disappointed if they do not do that in
any way shape or form but I gotta
imagine they're going to I I just don't
see a scenario where at least five ten
minutes of showing her on her own
showing that she can you know endure and
Survive by herself so I I'd be very
disappointed and very shocked if they
don't do that yes and if they could tone
down the wokeness that'd be great
but guys buy a shirt too and buy a shirt
please we start off with a snowy
abandoned neighborhood which we learn is
where Joel and Ali went to after them
all Upon returning home from hunting you
saw that Ellie had hitched up somewhere
like this and they really managed to
recapture the look of the location
similar to The Source materials if you
find gel in the basement on a mattress
and Ellie's been doing DIY surgery in
order to try and heal him and now we can
also catch an empty tool rack and these
have all been taken and likely used for
weapons it reminded me of the kind of
houses you'd find in the game where
everything had been picked clean because
I'd been spamming the triangle button
now Jill tells me and last week he of
course wanted him to take it his worst
fears come true and he's put her in a
lot of danger and is now holding her
back Joel is very much the kind of
person who would just ditch someone who
was in this position because in this
world he it doesn't really allow for
hangers on as she puts Dakota see
genuine love in his eyes and he realizes
this is more than what he's had before
but there's she even said that he didn't
really love her and they were just
together because they were both good at
surviving he very much sees Ali as his
second daughter though and she views him
as the father that she never had now we
sort of get a similar pot device to Left
Behind and as something new happen in
that we then cut to the Past Ellie's
about to step out of the basement at
this point now he flashed back to her in
a federal training camp I know we keep
pausing a lot but I gotta say what I
like about the addition of Joel being
out of it as he's dying is that in the
game he's very much just unconscious
yeah and here Pedro's awake you know
he's suffering and he's like on the
verge of just passing out the whole time
but I like that you get to see him
become very emotional because he he's a
master at communicating through his eyes
oh yeah which does wonders for him when
he's the Mandalorian
I think uh I think that was great to see
it here yeah we can see that she has a
Walkman and this is something that she
also had in the comic uh comic and here
listening to all in on by Pearl Jam
they're quite important band in the
franchise and the song Future Days was a
thing that constantly popped up
throughout at the time of part two's
release it was a big thing about how the
song didn't actually get released by the
time that outbreak happened however
Naughty Dog pointed out that they'd done
a live show where they played it so the
characters could actually know this song
honestly I don't think people would have
cared because it is quite sad obsessing
over this type of stuff about the
outbreak was moved forward 10 years for
the show so that song pops up yeah I'm
gonna [__] kick off a [__] furious
this moment is pretty much the academy
in the comics and it's clear they wanted
to tie back to that often overlooked
Last of Us offshoot did you know there
were Comics I did know there were
economics no no there were Comics but I
have not read any oh my God what
I know what elusive learning this I want
to buy some Comics I understood that
reference by the way and I understood
that you should buy a shirt while you're
right I do need to get one but yeah no I
I do need to get on the comics I know
I'm an evil evil man I I don't love Last
of Us enough but I I should I really
should get on the comics for sure damn
that's shocking and no oh wait and that
we saw Ellie with Riley Ross yeah she's
already left the bullies that
capitalizing this and one called Bethany
rips her headphones off and taunts her
for having no one to fight her battles
it's clear Ali gravitates towards
authority figures and Riley is very much
a prototype gel protector figure we
learned from Captain Kwong that she's
been acting differently the last couple
of weeks since Riley left and her friend
departing is another example of someone
leaving here Ellie never really got to
know her mother she was palmed off by
Marlene test died and Jill tried to get
rid of her with Tommy you can see why
she told Sam she was tired of being
alone like Al Green and I think it's
really good writing to sell the C sheets
of this in this flashback moment it's
clear everyone is ties to the past they
hold on to just like Ellie does and we
see that even Captain Kwong has trouble
letting go he has a faded picture of his
family on his desk and I'm guessing he's
died during the initial outbreak now
Ellie's beans several times before and
instead of punishing her Quang wants to
give her some advice He suggests that
she aims to be an officer and
demonstrates this path by throwing down
his keys the first path is a cub and the
second being Keys is symbolic because
this will open up doors for her it also
added a really cool is that a naughty
dog too and we catch the naughty dog oh
no way I just noticed that a
conversation in scene is very much
another side of fedra that we haven't
seen before in the game they are pretty
much always your enemies yeah those are
the bandits that you encounter along the
way
you press the pause button I'm sorry no
one has authority to press this face
Mark by the way buy a shirt I do like
though that they have expanded upon you
know the the military with fedra a
little bit in terms of showing from
their perspective because obviously as
Paul just mentioned in the game
everything was from Joel and Ellie's
perspective and Tess as well when we
were in that portion of the game so you
really just only viewed them as the bad
guys you know you realize in this show
everything's not just black and white if
there is some gray area there when it
comes to fedra so I actually do like
that they have expanded on them and just
again just seeing everything from their
point of view and there is a reason why
they do the things that they do I'm not
saying I I'm fully behind everything
they do but I I understand why they do
it it makes for an interesting drama at
least you know and perspective just from
seeing their point of view on the show
you press the space bar first I know I
did I did I'm so sorry no I agree it's
very last of us too to be doing it
however this Series has shown things
from that point of view because in the
game we will lock to Joe and Ellie's
perspective really shows you all these
kinds of points of views and it allows
you to actually sympathize with them
Huang believes that fedra is the only
thing holding the world together and
that if they go down the world will fall
apart in Kansas City we saw things were
like a federal house did and the people
there were carrying out murders and just
doing horrible things Federer also
helped to push the infected underground
there and Kathleen's need for Revenge
unleash this on her people now in her
room we catch some dinosaur drawings and
also a picture of some moon cycles we'll
go over what these are two things being
Ellie's interests are very very
important we also get to know pun
intended book by Will Livingston and her
life is just slightly below it out of
view this is actually volume one or as
we see Riley busting out Volume 2 later
on this is a a slight change up from the
game as in those they found it in the
mall when coming across A hermits Camp
Riley then read it as you made your way
through or as yeah she has it already
oh I got something else and in the game
that goes on for a very very long time
and I loved every second of it yeah no I
love that they give you that option in
the game like you can either like stop
listening to the pun jokes or you can
keep going and yeah I always every time
I play I'm like no I want to keep
hearing them they got so much in there
and it's cool that they draw a parallel
with that in the relationship with Joel
of carrying that over you know I think
that's really makes it stronger
absolutely it helps you know just bring
the bond together for sure between the
two absolutely buy shirt you also catch
Charlie reading a Savage Starlight comic
which I think is titled negentrippy
Nugent trippy anyway I don't know
episode 5 video we talking about how
these were Collectibles I eat pick up in
the game and again trippy issue was
something that he came across on your
travels we see the inside of it being a
big action scene involving a man and a
woman bursting their way into somewhere
probably reaching uh but I think this is
very much how Ali views her and Joel and
the guy in the book even looks slightly
similar to how he does in the game
doesn't he well he is sure either way
sure
[Music]
well that's not too long until she
returns but we get another tour of her
room and see some tapes the top one by
aha foreshadows a great moment in the
second game near the James one plays
into this episode later on I got you
babe it's a song we hear Riley and Ellie
dancing to at the end and this music was
also what they jammed away to in the
mall on Riley's fate for last night you
also see a poster for Mortal Kombat
I just played that in an arcade the
other day I saw his alien Joel came
across a cabinet for it which in the
game was a fighter called the turning it
started a character called Angel knives
but with the show being a Warner
Brothers property they have the rights
to use the Mortal Kombat characters I
think that the game developers likely
knew this was going to be an Easter
Dragon advance and in the recent Last of
Us remake they actually added in a
Mortal Kombat
sticking her hand over Ali's mouth this
is slightly different to the game
is of course foreshadowed her fate and
let's play the scene side by side so you
can see what they kept and also what
they changed I love these
I would have pretended
[Music]
Riley
laughs
now
Riley owl
I landed on my hip what the hell
I thought I Was Bitten I know it was
kind of Awesome
[Music]
you're not gonna kill me are you
see you
and I don't even know how long 45 days
well
46 technically
so
is it going I thought you were dead
on for three weeks
wanna know what I've been up to
I'm
I thought you were dead
are you okay I'm fine I just ran away
for a bit that's all here
look
no way where were you
I joined the Firefly oh [__] you
you're a firefly
you're a firefly Jesus
are we cool
I disappeared and you're mad
and I owe you an explanation
let's get out of here and I'll tell you
all about it we'll tell you everything
first you have to promise me something
it's almost morning and I have military
drills
you know where we learn how to kill
fireflies not going anywhere with you
it's great it's 2 A.M in a few hours I
have drills
fireflies
put some pants on and let's go
grass
so there are some slight changes there
but lots of similarities too I do like
that for the show they chose to play
with a more immediate intensity versus
the way how Riley kind of is in the game
is she seems to be trying to brush off
anything that's serious whereas the
actress plays into the fact like no I
got some like something concerning and
serious that I will be telling you a
little bit later which works whereas the
Riley in the game is kind of concealing
that side of herself and is just trying
to play off like no we're just gonna
have a good time that's all that matters
today we're just gonna have a good time
like I don't want you to think about the
fact that I'm leaving we're just gonna
have a good time you know yeah and also
the way they play into Ellie's passion
with aligning herself with fedra and
Riley's passion for aligning herself
with the fireflies that is a starting
point for their dynamic in the show
where as you even see here Ellie doesn't
seem too perturbed by it you know I like
both versions uh the video game how she
pretends to bite her and then in this
one where she kind of just covers her
mouth in a more serious uh way but I
personally like the video game one just
a little bit more where she snuck up on
her and tried to bite her just I don't
know because I I just love that aspect
of their relationship they're very
joking with each other and there were
certain things again that I liked in the
video game a little bit more whereas
here I thought there were some
interesting and better choices that they
made in the TV show but again they both
worked for me Riley is now a firefly and
he should not still ahead of the map but
picking up the sort of Romeo and Juliet
Vibes here with them being on opposite
sides
in the game as you're cutting between
timelines he join alien Riley jumping
into an abandoned Apartment block which
is why here trucks outside
[Music]
that was close huh however here we see
them very much moving through the
streets as trucks travel through looking
for people breaking curfew eventually go
down into an Alleyway and then into this
which is when they bust out the torches
at least doesn't work and she has to hit
it time to time
in the game we learned how Riley became
a firefly which I'm gonna play with the
show version so you can see how things
slightly differ remember that Firefly
you bet installed his gun
yeah I remember him that's Trevor I saw
him walking down the street so I tailed
his ass one night you were in the hole
I got bored so I snuck out I follow him
into this alley and all these fireflies
Ambush me
they took me right to their Hideout to
Marlene I was on my way back being
stealthy like I am and this chick popped
out of nowhere chick like our age no
like 40. were you scared
terrified I thought this time she would
actually shoot me but instead she just
says what took you so long whatever
anyways old she said she was impressed
watching me sneak around avoiding guards
she was expecting me and she just made
you a firefly something like that and
she asked what I thought about fedra so
I told her the truth their fascistic
bags and they're the ones that should be
getting hanged for their crimes that
hole almost killing me thing was a test
she wanted to know I was committed
oh
she's like all right do you want in
you're in
that's it I'm in the show the woman
she's talking about is clearly Marlene
who recruit her personally or as in the
game she was brought to her makes it
seem like Marlene's been keeping an eye
on Ellie for a long time and that she's
now has those around her too eventually
if she had someone on her side that was
close to Ellie Ellie would be warmer to
her and it also explains why her
fireflies didn't immediately kill Ellie
when she was bitten Moline has a close
attachment with Ellie very good safe and
knowing Riley might have helped with
that however it could also be the
reasoning why she shipped Riley off as
she didn't want her running away with
her friend we discover later on that
Riley actually asked if Ali could join
her but Marlene said no she just wanted
to keep her in the qz and potentially
they may have moved Riley for that
reason now in the apollon block they
also find a guy who seemingly overdosed
on pills Ali and Joel of course come
from the same QC that's possible even
sold him these as they are similar to
what we saw him dealing in episode one
ironic with Abby if in some ways they've
already cross paths via pills pills they
unite everyone they bring everyone
together enough to change the name of
the show The Last of the pills
no
the last of the shirts
I'm failing guys
it could be teasing the danger that Joel
has around him and how his actions have
a negative effect on people now a body
lying against the wall like this is also
somehow very much foreshadows infected
later on most of those that have
quarters yeah body and growing out their
face and they'd eventually hit a point
where they knew they were going to die
if they didn't become full-on clickers
thus they'd head to a wall lay down die
and grow into it and in the games they'd
spread out spores the other one in the
mall isn't dead he's very much following
the same pattern and the body against
the wall here at least so haunting it
collapses through the floor and they
take his boots with them and drink it on
the roof Ali pretends to love it and
this is a complete opposite of the
campfire scene in which he sped it
straight out she's trying to impress
Riley and we do see a different side to
her here for Christ's sakes Paul in the
game there's a drinking moment that
brought this up the last video what are
you doing man I'm gonna play some of the
clip here's some of the clip awesome
sure
sure oh
oh my god oh here it's disgusting see
it's the one thing I have to hold on to
that was a good reference in the Easter
egg that well you caught I mean I I
noticed it too right away but yeah yeah
way to toot your own horn I'm the one
who said it
yeah I mean at least he kind of still
mentioned the drink but yeah no I I feel
you it's in the game yeah it is it's in
the game wasn't it mentioned I don't
understand Paul now we learned that it's
not the first Dead buddy Riley scene and
that she's witnessed her parents corpses
most of the kids take it in by fedra
were orphans and this allowed them to
train the kids to be soldiers if you
have ties to your family and stuff
you're less likely to be loyal to things
like fedra especially when they're
oppressing the very people you're
connected with Jedi can't work that way
too well he's gone and we then see our
obsessing over it this is something
she's done throughout the series and
Neil lure of power means a lot to her as
she's not really experienced the bad
side of it at this point they talk about
fedra and also the fireflies Riley sees
them as fascist whereas Ellie sees them
as holding everything together Riley
thinks the fireflies are gonna bring
freedom but we've already seen from
Kathleen the kind of thing it leads to
yeah she ended a promising Fair trials
that people would live if they gave up
others and in the end this was shown to
all just be a lie Pedro also do terrible
things too think what it boils down to
is that no matter what happens the worst
traits of humanity will always emerge in
some form or another no matter decide we
gotta keep order man good sides too and
obviously these sides have their appeals
as well in the end though whichever side
is in charge will oppress the other side
in some form and thus we get these
divisions that lead to others attempting
to seek power when they finally get it
they want to punish you the side who now
become the oppressed ones and the cycle
starts again Riley later brings up how
fedra have stopped people and in the
game when he got to Pittsburgh you found
graffiti talking about how the people
there were famished Ellie said it didn't
hover the fireflies bomb the storage
Depot which Riley sees as being
propaganda hit up any social media site
you're gonna see people talking about
the faults in the other political side
whilst dismissing their own I think
Ellie and Riley show we can find common
ground with stuff like this so Trump and
Biden supporters can get along
Paul just taught me that Paul just
unified an entire I mean he missed a big
reference in last episode but he just
might have unified an entire country
that's right guys that's what Paul's all
about unifying unifying it's time to
make this an alt-right Channel
[Laughter]
now Riley says that the fireflies don't
carry out attacks when civilians are
involved but tell that to test and
Robert now in the game there was an
extra Dimension to this as there was an
announcement that said there hadn't been
an affection for 30 days Riley said this
was a lie and that it was just covered
up I kind of I was hoping that this
would appear in the show as we of course
saw Joel having to burn lots of bodies
in episode 1. this scene does kind of
mimic the game a bit as your first run
along rooftops before coming alongside
the mall like what we have here the pair
then dropped down through a collapsed
roof and they enter the Liberty Gardens
Mall this is the same as what the
location is called in the game and they
do rearrange things slightly originally
you saw the tunnel one it's poster which
was a water pistol I used against Riley
during one of the pairs final scenes
together it was the game across a 10 for
a man named Winston who he learned had
been living in the mall as recluse as I
mentioned earlier he was who you got the
pun bug from and you learned that he
died of old age in this world that's a
big thing as there's it's very much
survival of the fittest so making it to
that point really means a lot and
Winston's also where they got to drink
from I actually was waiting for him to
say that I was like oh he's gonna bring
it up right now I really do think though
I mean again I I pointed this out at the
end of the last episode one thing that
really bothered me in the episode again
I I love the episode overall they were
not doing a very good job of sneaking
right they were being Extremely Loud and
again I get it for the audience we need
to hear what they're saying in terms of
dialogue and audio I I get that but you
still be in a quiet tone and we can
still be able to hear them whereas if
you're talking loud and we're sneaking
around with fedra around it's not going
to be I'm not going to be able to
suspend my disbelief as much for that
and it's I'm gonna get now a little more
on the nitpicky side when it's done
throughout the entire sneaking about so
that got a little bit under my under my
skin as as you can tell but not as much
as you with the drink but I still agree
with you he's got to mention the drink
lazy bum now from here you went to the
Halloween shop and then you threw some
bricks at some call Windows to see who
could smash the most what the winner
smash the like button as well and then
from here the characters turned the
power on and went on the Merry-Go-Round
here though they flipped the power on
first before they head into the mall so
turns out the whole city has power
they just flipped the circuit breakers
all you gotta do is flip it back
so turns out when Federer connected that
block up to the grid this place got
connected too not that they know now at
this point we got a scene that's very
reminiscent of the game with Ellie
opening up a door into the mall in which
we see it all light up we also have a
play on the escalator scene which pulls
directly from that
whoa look at me
this is the first Wonder on the day now
and from here we catch a poster for dawn
of the wow yes I was gonna point that
out too but did he just not mention the
song or is that in the spoiler spoiler
section later on
look Paul we're making a list of
everything and we're coming for you
buddy this is yeah we're just watching
this video to see what you missed yeah
we we are the YouTube comments you put
hours of work into a video and we're
here to only tell you the couple of
things yeah you might have skipped over
my Curtis invite the two this was a
fictional My Life in The Last of Us
universe and here's what they had to say
about it in the game
dragged you to see that movie everywhere
I saw this not before the outbreak he
did
he totally get her by the end
nobody gets gutted it's a it's a dumb
team movie who dragged you to see at
them
I don't know always has his guard up
stay focused all right
I also love the little back in five
minutes sign and it shows just how much
people were caught off guard you're
right I'm good I know she likes to clear
your mouth on to throw it on camera yes
I do it's sometimes you sniff you go
let's find anything in that I'm so glad
I'm so glad we're pointing this out to
the internet something that more to make
fun of me because falling asleep on
camera wasn't enough in the last year
wait what when did you fall asleep on
camera on your brother's Channel that's
what happens at the Javi KOA channel the
guests fall asleep not here got too much
G fuel keeping us alert
take that jabby this guy just popped out
for a poo and didn't end up coming back
everything happened really quick but
Footlocker and probably also get loads
of toilet paper yes again added a
lingerie scene with Ellie trying to
Smart herself up after Riley makes a
joke about imagining her in it from here
we go to the Merry-Go-Round which pulls
directly from the PlayStation classic
it's probably the most memorable part of
Left Behind and in the game it's chewing
this that Riley gets out the pun book
symbolically merry-go-rounds are a sign
of innocence and simplicity that puts
horrified
so they're often used as sources of
magic and adventure and carousels like
this are commonplace at amusement parks
as they bring joy to lots of people this
is just the pair enjoying what for their
missile last night on earth before a
major change happens though Ellie
doesn't know it Riley is well aware he's
meant to be going away and either way
Ellie is about to lose her forever now
similar what happens in the game The
Ride breaks down and it spoils the
moment the phone is cut short
very much foreshadowing the journey that
plays ahead and we discovered that Riley
was about to turn 17 and that she'd been
assigned to sewage detail this is all
that Quang thought she was good for and
you can see why she ended up running
away racist Fred ran the duties assigned
to people were very much prisons
themselves and in this world people
didn't really have the freedom to do
what they want no one was lucky enough
to just sit around talking about movies
all day and you can see why people
gravitate towards the promise of freedom
and Liberation now on the merry-go-round
in the game Riley busts out the pun book
but here they kind of skip over it save
it for later and just go straight to the
photo booth the show being set 10 years
earlier does mean that they can't bring
send things over and in the game it
ended Facebook if you wanted to share
your photos to Facebook neither knew
what that was and instead he got
printouts of the photos before the whole
thing shut down in a nice fourth wall
breaking moment you could actually share
the photos you made in game to your own
Facebook and that was an oh really
sensation explaining to my dad why I was
posting pictures of you who are those
two girls like what um
we get the little bunny mascot however
the names changed up because of the
whole Facebook thing the game has it
being called sharesnap or as the show is
star shot because they couldn't have
posted it online with it being said in
2003 yeah Facebook wasn't around then
and it's genuinely one of my favorite
Easter eggs in the entire show and I
love when they put this much thought
into it now from here they go into the
arcade we see machines for Tetris
Frogger attack from Mars and Daytona USA
there's no shot for shot with the to see
the scene with the with the taking the
photos it's so it's so similar
it's like almost identical look it's not
like you you missed something but
lazy lazy Paul hours of work wasted this
was about driving across the country
which may be a link to Joel and Ellie
doing it as as 2C said also in the game
Ellie jumped into Jack and Daxter
machine and naughty dog of course made
that game also worth pointing out that
Ellie's wearing the shirt that we saw
her wearing in episode 1 and this was
also the show that Young Nathan Drake
brought in Uncharted three anyway in the
show Ellie gets to play Mortal Kombat 2
whereas in the game The Turning cabinet
didn't actually work instead Riley
described the game
and he was the most memorable part for
me yeah I'm guessing Naughty Dog didn't
have the resources to design The
Mechanics for a fighting game for what
amounted to about two minutes in the
game but here we catch them playing it
out they go to the Deadpool stage and a
Deadpool is when you bet on who's gonna
die but my entire house on Riley and now
moving to Vegas baby I still do prefer
the video game yeah yeah it feels more
intimate you know especially for the
connection that they're building yeah
like this is more relatable
is way more relatable to be bonding over
this in that regard but yeah just using
the imagination because I I remember
playing that part and getting swept up
in it myself yes and then I'm I'm
imagining it with her because it's like
he feels like a little cringy and Goofy
at first and then you get lost in it and
you're like oh this is effective and you
are creating a memory together I agree
with you it's much more relatable for us
but I I love the vivid imagination not
only you know that neo-druckman and the
writers came up with in the game but I
just like again just showing the bond
and like Riley like I don't care what
the situation is I'm gonna find a way to
help Ellie and cheer her up in this
moment and let her get his imagination
yeah yeah but get the feeling of playing
the game even if it doesn't work it just
showed like Riley has a certain level of
you know going to whatever extreme she
needs to to make sure she she helps and
pleases her friend and I just thought it
was really interesting and Broad and
really delicate cool choice that they
chose to do that same like because I
remember the first time playing that
scene like I don't know how this is
gonna work like just imagine the
character and then has the scene like
kept on going I was like this is really
freaking cool yeah I love this it's
strong yeah and then every time I played
him like I'm like really looking forward
to this part again because I'm not I
love that part that's great and it shows
them as like their children using their
imaginations to escape and I think a big
part of survival of survival instincts
oftentimes if you're a child it has to
be a Survivor oftentimes a great way of
escapism is using your imagination so I
liked having that be implemented for the
characters and I feel like you kind of
detract that I mean of course you
haven't played the game you're not gonna
give a [__] yeah of course yeah this is
straight up just a flashback only
whereas in the game it's a cross between
a flashback and also in present time
she's looking as Paul mentioned earlier
she's looking for the medical supplies
for Joel to uh you know sew him back up
with his wounds so in the University of
Eastern Colorado mall so yes yes thank
God you specified it
anyway Riley chooses my Lena and she
pulls off her fatality which Ellie
described her as doing back in episode
three there's this one character named
Molina who takes off her mask and she
has monster teeth and then she swallows
you whole and bursts out your bones you
should get the Liu King fatality into
one of the infected who's been awakened
by the lights coming on and all the
noise he's located in a toy shop and
this is very much a symbol of Innocence
which he ends up destroying we see two
dolls here and this could be a reference
to the two mannequins in the closed shop
stand which is where the attack happens
in the game yeah they just shrink it
down so that it happens in the Halloween
store rather than them going there I
think the change from mannequins to
dolls again is to hammer home this
creepy factor and also the idea that
this is Ellie's childhood being
destroyed as things drastically change
from this point onwards she's no longer
under the production of fedra and is
basically made to flee the qz with Joel
now from here Riley takes Ellie to Macho
Nacho this is another great night dog
Easter egg and in inside Nate asked
Elena if she actually used to work there
you came across this in the morning as
well and now they've brought across the
show where O'Reilly was camped out at
that's the fun book comes out and we
hear the ones which all to show up in
the game what did the frustrated
cannibal do frustrated cannibal threw up
his hands
[Music]
laid on me he threw up his hands what
did the triangle say to the circle
you're pointless what did the triangle
say to the circle
pointless you
oh in the back Ellie discovers that
Riley's been making explosives and that
she was actually posted here by the
fireflies these look identical to some
of the weapons you get in part two and
as Ellie goes over you can see that on
the top shelf there is a federal
container they likely were gonna
deliberate using guerrilla warfare to
take them out Riley promises Ali that
they wouldn't be used on her but there's
absolutely no way that Riley could
guarantee that say Ellie did become an
officer then she would be the kind of
person they target and we see how people
are very much forced to go against each
other I like the game we learned this is
our last night in Boston and it plays
off the back of this scene Ellie I'm
leaving
they've asked me to leave
leave what
Boston
I'm supposed to join a group in another
city
they're sending me to a post in the
Atlantic cutesy
I argued with them to stay here
I asked if you
could so we could go together
you know how Marlene is
nothing's easy with her everything's a
test but Marlene said no the [__] is
Marley Marlene is the lady that helped
me it doesn't matter
they're picking me up tomorrow
tonight's my last night in Boston
why did you bring me here
I wanted to see you
because I wanted to see you no why did
you bring me here
I don't know now the Atlanta QC is
always something we hear about in the
game when you're in Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh was a city that had
overthrown Federer and we discovered
that some of the remnants ended up
fleeing and going to Atlanta in a
Halloween store we see a decoration
popping out of a grave and this is
similar the creature bursting out of the
coffin in the game counterpart Riley
gives her the pun Buck explaining first
about it and she talks about the doubt
that she has going with them however
Riley says because Ali never had a
family she doesn't understand even with
the bad you still accept people and
later on when Joel becomes his surrogate
father she very much accepts all looking
bad things in him Ali's being put
through the ringer and she goes through
how Riley left her gave her this amazing
night and is then leaving her again I
think Ellie gets so attached to people
that she's willing to let them walk all
over her to some extent and believe
their lies because it's easier than
losing them Riley says she's sure about
leaving and Ellie says that she'll miss
her which is when Riley gives her a
werewolf mask whilst Riley gets a clown
one the characters wore both these masks
along with
he ended up doing her best role in the
werewolf one which was a really fun way
to start off the mold section
which is when he had a water pistol
fight using the typhoon Blitz which he
saw a sign for early on after this Riley
put the tape on and he danced on top of
the table like what we get here it's
side by side time and just be aware that
we've muted the music here for copyright
reasons a bit awkward but that's YouTube
so really quick you already noticed
playing the DLC on that Super Soaker
fight hmm try not to spoil there's a
fight in part two with another woman you
know what you thought I'm talking about
there's only one other woman she fights
yeah yeah I know what you're saying now
I know and it kind of reminded me of
that in a way except you know not as
violent or as intense and not with water
no this is but it's like that's kind of
setting the ground for that that's an
interesting uh or foreshadowing that you
picked up there because I never even
thought about that but yeah no because
that's the only other time she fights
someone with a stage like that you know
what I'm saying people who played the
game for you without going into too much
spoilers yeah I mean once we get into
the spoiler Talk part you I guess we can
get into that nah we'll save it I'm over
it we'll save it for season two save for
season five
[Music]
sorry but really come here
what is it don't go
what's wrong the DLC
I first played this one
I impressed myself when she said that
yeah
got flowers
in the spring yeah
I'm sorry
it's good
what do we do now
[Music]
we'll figure it out
what do we do now
but I don't think Marlene's gonna wait
[Music]
I like in the game the moment is ruined
by the infected one thing I have
criticized the show for is that I think
they kind of missed out on the bigger
infected moments from the game such as
the skyscraper and the hotel basement
sections this was another way they
lessened it a bit and removed the Panic
of running through the mall the chase
ended with it seeming like he got out
but the scaffolding fell and Ellie
plummeted down Riley jumped back down
and this was very much a giving up her
life to save Ellie yeah she ends up
saving her as well but to me the impact
of having her jump back into the fire is
kind of lessened a bit now we did go
back and forth at the Kevin spoilers
office over why they changed it to the
one infected and our editor Matt
actually said that she wouldn't have
been as scared of The Horde in episode 5
if she'd already seen one that was the
first time this version of Ali
experienced it and therefore it wouldn't
have made sense if she'd seen one before
personally I think it's just a budget
thing and having to film a Chase through
a mall would obviously cost and you'd
have to loot more than Footlocker to get
that back should call it loot Locker not
the time of place I mean yeah I feel
like it might ultimately come down to
budgetary restraints I mean it's more
effective in the in this in the game for
the fact of you're running and running
and running away and you think and it's
like you think you got this cathartic
release where oh I've escaped I've done
it and then you're like oh never mind
right so you you do have that effect but
I think this does Hammer home a little
bit more of the physicality of the
weight of just what it's like dealing
which is one of these guys and they're
two young girls you know so they're not
like physically the strongest of taking
on it's a more realistic situation where
they can just take on one as opposed to
running away from several but again
understand the situation of the stress
of it but again I agree with you but and
I understand like we had just gotten
this incredible horde and action
sequence where they showed so much so I
can imagine a lot of the budget went
towards that in terms of using affected
for their action sequences so I I truly
understand why but I think too like you
just said I kind of like that they did
just show one because again it shows how
hard it is just to defeat one of them
and again like you said it's it's two
little girls so I mean it makes sense
honestly anyway back in the present
Ellie guys have another house and
desperately searches for something to
help Joe shout out to all my Gamers who
know what it's like hammering that
triangle button constantly as you open
up every draw for a bit just a little
bit of cloth or something now the
frustrationally has here is married in
the past without lashing out in anger
and smashing the glass like it's a
button with a thumbs up on it we get a
similar shock composition to the game
and in the end Riley makes a pack that
they just lose their minds together
[Music]
okay
thank you
I love Riley's reaction there's some
more stuff over there you can break
there's more stuff over there you can
breathe
wait I see it we got two options
the way I see him we've got two options
option one
you take the easy way out
one
to take the easy way out it's quick and
painless
I'm not a fan of option one I
know I don't like option one
two
we fight
fight for what
we should just keep going
we're gonna turn into one of those
things
[Music]
there are million ways we should have
died before today
and a million ways we can die before
tomorrow
but we fight
for every second we get to spend with
each other I love that cut back in the
game
two minutes
two days I don't want to give that up
whether it's two minutes
or two days
we don't give that up
left behind I don't want to give that up
my vote
[Music]
let's just wait it out
you know we can
be all poetic and just lose our minds
together
it's beautiful I can
[__]
oh it's option three
what's option three
sorry
that really Ramsay [__] really made
it their own and they really they really
killed it
really did
sorry I'm sorry let's get out of here
yeah
it was not mimicking in any way yeah it
really made it their own
foreign
[Music]
this is also a line reference in the
game by Ellie when she discusses her
past Boston
back when I Was Bitten
I wasn't alone
my best friend was there
she got bit too
we didn't know what to do
so
she says
let's just wait it out
you know we can be all poetic and just
lose our minds together
also did a bit of deep digging and the
mall in the game was apparently built in
1968 with the show of course starting
off in that year now back in the
presents
make sure you sanitize that mate yeah
it's been been sat in a draw for 20
years probably probably causing
infection never mind then you go but
clearly Ellie is fine
this is clearly because she lost Riley
she doesn't want to repeat of that and
she very much mirrors Jill not wanting
to go through losing his daughter again
they found each other and someone to
fight for and we end with Ali stitching
up his wound in order to stop the
bleeding this shot is framed to marry
the ending of last week's episode and
whereas that was a tower now to finish
on this is a more hopeful that closes
out the episode and before we get into
the spoiler section of the video I
thought I'd give my thoughts as a
standalone thing I did enjoy this
adaptation of the Left Behind DLC but I
don't know if I'm a bit too close to the
game yeah I think so we were saying
comparison and was just hoping things
like The Horde and the the winter Mall
sections would have been carried across
I think at this point I'm kind of just
accepting that the series will always
just strip back the game so it mainly
focuses on the human moments anything
that leaves stuff being so repetitive at
points though and every episode other
than four and six I believe basically
introduces one or two new characters and
they then kill off at the end so it is
all good to be fair but I think this
formula almost stops it from being great
those first five episodes especially
were Classics but the last two have kind
of dropped for me personally still good
oh I love sex feel the constraints of
the series are starting to show a bit
now stormery did a really good job as
Riley and though I probably sound like
I'm bashing it I do think that viewed in
a vacuum that this episode's really good
I just think of this show as a whole it
needs a bit more variety from the
formula that we're getting maybe I am
too close to the game like I said but it
never really felt like they were
following a format or if they were then
it wasn't clear from that initial
playthrough anyway if you're loving this
show and everything that it does and
hopefully you can at least see things
from my point of view and if you haven't
played the game no I hate you you know
we're lucky that we have both these two
adaptations and and there were there's
definitely going to be people who are
like well I prefer the game and people
who are like I prefer the show so yeah
everyone's gonna have that oh you're
supposed to be the unifier we want boobs
how much I love the game and and all the
stupid little references I mean he
unified Republicans and Democrats or Joe
Biden supporters and Donald Trump
supporters really but you can't get
video game and TV shows coward British
coward are there people who've played
the game who would say that they prefer
the show I've not met plenty of people
who are like who are who played the game
and love the show and I met people who
haven't played the game and loved the
show but I I don't I haven't met someone
yet who's like I think you know season
one ends but so far I think I might like
the show more I haven't met someone who
feels that way I've Just Seen over
resounding positive feelings towards the
show I haven't really seen too many I
only like the game the show is CR I have
rarely have ever seen that so definitely
heard that oh no I'm not saying I had I
have two people yeah I just said it I
just said it's rare I'm not saying I
have not heard it at all it's internet
you're gonna hear I mean some negativity
but yeah it's it's been resounding
positive but yeah I just I haven't met
anyone yet who's like I preferred the
show so far I mean I feel like there's
things the show has done better yeah
definitely for sure anyway that takes to
the spoiler section and that yeah we
have a couple of things that I heavily
into part two red planet most of the
items in Ali's room have a payoff down
the line and at one point we catch those
dinosaur drawings
Cycles in the arcade Ali also asks if
the next surprise is a dinosaur and
these all tie together for where gel
takes her on her birthday the pig got to
a museum and this is filled with
dinosaurs and that's the one that Ali
ends up getting into being through that
a number of times so sorry we're
constantly repeating it but they also
referenced it around the campfire last
week for sure yeah tape and take on me
playing in the mall returns in a big
moment during part two as well
it's a great vision and I wanted to play
it in the video but we got hit with
copyright claims so I can't but I'm
gonna serenade you with it now as we
Fade Out so click you've got to either
listen to me or click a video on the end
screen talking
[Music]
it's okay
thank you
take me
[Music]
I was not expecting that that was
beautiful beautiful huh light on the
super spoilery section today but that
was a great way to end it ah another
fantastic video Paul another despite the
fact that you obviously hate this show
based off what you said there there's
only one way to take it you either love
it or hate it and I um it's pretty
obvious you obviously hate it this show
is the Last Jedi for him you do have the
best breakdowns on it I'm saying it
saying it loud and proud today despite
the drink thing despite the drink thing
freaking thing you keep missing buddy
you're going down Paul anyway guys
follow Andrew on Twitter and Instagram
at agor711 you can catch him on the
jabic away Channel falling asleep and
here he's wide awake just with some
sniffles and clearing of the throats
let's send this with a
Brandon Benzie how long have you been a
patron of ours Andrew I want you to take
a guess for how long he's been a patron
of ours go ahead I'm gonna go with how
many years I've known you so it's been
eight years a minute ago eight years you
think Brandon benzie's been a patron yes
I'm gonna that we have not had the
patreon that long but that's a hell of a
guess you want to do round two all right
let's go with four years four years all
right here it is uh I was close less
than a year very close but you've been
you're you're one year anniversary is
coming up for us in in five months my
dude at a little less than five months
and I hope you're still around here in
those five months so what I want you to
do buddy is if you can just send me a
message and answer me three questions
three questions here it is one what
other Patron accounts are you pledged to
I hope it's the answer is done
two have you seen the jabby COA Channel
if so what are your thoughts it better
be negative three
who's your favorite guest on this
channel if you say this guy I know
you're just pandering
Brandon thanks for being here for so
long and showing your support I hope you
also uh increased your pledge all for
this great shout out but you know you
can do instead of increasing that pledge
I sure you could use that money to buy a
shirt
love you Brandon Benzie thanks for being
here cowboy
[Music]